Listening to radio lab radio from
W. N. Y. S. T. Yup. N.
N. P. R. Okay. Hello.
Hello? Hello. Hello. How are you?
We are super, super excited to
talk with you. Oh, same. And me,
I'm sorry about the delay and so, oh,
it's fine. No, it wasn't busy days.
Life is crazy. Life is crazy. I know.
But uh, you were so enthusiastic,
so I just, I need to talk to
these guys. They really mean it.
This is Alex Alexandre. Gemar Gundam.
Are you Norwegian all the way back?
Yeah. Typical Norwegian, you know,
if typical includes things like biking
in Sahara and climbing Everest and things
like that. He's kind of a,
a professional adventurer.
And we got him into the studio because
he made a video last year on one of his
trips. I tell you this video,
it's maybe the most amazing
Internet video I have ever seen.
I think so too.
So let me just set the
scene for you. Okay.
What you see in the video is this
Guy Alex kind of moving along this,
he's on skis, this snowy snow
scape. Hmm. He's filming himself.
He's got the camera in his right hand.
Where is he exactly? Antarctica. Oh,
he's on a three month track to the
South Pole and back by himself.
And what he'd been doing is every
couple of days on his trip, you know,
every 200 kilometers. And so he
would bury stuff in the snow, some,
some fuel and uh, and sometimes a
little bit of gear that I didn't use.
Was that just to lighten
your load? Yeah. You know,
cause every ounce of unneeded
weight has to go. So in this video,
it's date 86, almost
three months since I left.
That's three months of walking 10
hours a day and I lost almost 25 kilos.
55 pounds. He's exhausted.
Oh,
he's come upon his last cash.
So on the last cash where
this video is captured,
what you see is Alex Neil in the
snow start to dig about lockdown.
I'm telling you that I'm quite hungry.
Whatever's in this last cash and the snow,
it's been three months since he buried it.
So I didn't really recall what was there.
[inaudible] he helps it sound good.
So he digs up this bag of stuff,
starts rifling through it.
There's a it and [inaudible].
It's gasoline, some zinc ointment.
It's just a mess.
Nothing. It's pretty much all press.
Excuse me. [inaudible]
okay, but then, Yup.
Yeah,
yeah.
[inaudible]
he holds up.
She struggles devil back
of cheese doodles. Yeah.
Yeah. [inaudible]
then he throws it up in the air. Yeah.
[inaudible]
and then this is, this
is my favorite part.
He just freezes and he's staring
off into the distance. Almost like,
did that happen on red color?
Is it real? So he starts to dig some more
and then
bye bye.
[inaudible]
look, look. This time huge chocolate bar.
It's milk chocolate and then it's
just like he finds the mentos.
I find [inaudible]
more and more and more.
Have you ever been that happy in your
life? Well, I've been thinking about that.
How? When did you shout
last time you were so happy.
I think that's why we've been watching
this video over and over again because
none of us can remember.
It's like what stands between you and
that feeling is a really interesting
question. Yeah. It's a
free mounts with hunger.
Actually,
I think the reason I liked this video
so much is not just because he's happy.
He said he somehow stumbled
into this moment of perfection.
It's just like a perfect situation by
being so tired and so hungry and finding
such a stash of candy that he
had forgotten that he left.
He created a moment of just
absolute complete bliss.
[inaudible]
in this hour on Radiolab,
we're going to be searching for
moments like Alex had up in Antarctica.
We're going to be searching for
bliss, bliss of all different sorts,
perfect moments,
perfect worlds kind of blistered slips
right through your fingers and the kind
of bliss that just might last and last.
All right, we're going to
begin with a story that, uh,
kind of inspired this show.
We would have never done a
show about the word bliss,
where it not for the following
story, which is about a bliss. A,
what do you mean a battle? That'll
make sense in just a second.
A story comes from our producer Tim
Howard, and it begins with a box of tapes.
Uh, alright, so check it
out. This is in my office.
And you've got a rectangular
package here. What is,
what is a very old looking box?
Doesn't look like much. It's just about
like 15 cassettes. Tip Number six,
singing and playing to
friends in America. No, Yo.
Uh, okay. So this is Charles
Charles Casey yield bliss,
an amazing character. And
that's Richard Richard Juror.
He's a fellow who gave me the cassettes.
You as a friend of Charles. Yeah.
So these were just like sitting
in his attic or something, garage.
He looked like, I suppose a little gnome,
a little leprechaun almost
to live. He was short,
bald and laughter the whole time.
He was a lovable character. Simple
as that. This is my favorite one.
[inaudible] Nicholas. Yet we just like,
just explain why we're
talking about this guy. Sure.
Because these tapes tell an amazing
story about a guy who really embodied his
name
and he tried to save the world,
but ultimately just tried too hard
the donor would follow to avoid
to my life. Kay. [inaudible]
Hey, we can start the story here.
This is from a lecture that he gave
decades later. So the story goes,
it's 1908 and he's a little kid living
in what's now the Ukraine. Okay.
And His name is Carl blitz, not
terrace buss, not Charles Bliss,
Carl Blitz, B. L. I. T. Z.
That's his original name.
And a little Carl was fascinated by
a tales of discovering adventure.
My name is Erica Okrent.
Erica wrote about Charles Bliss in
this great book called in the land of
invented languages. Getting back
to the story one day, she says,
when Carl was 11,
a lecture came through town about some
polar expedition Kohler expedition to
explorers talking about their
track across the North Pole.
And he was so inspired by what he saw
and heard at that lecture that even
decades later he couldn't talk about it.
Um, my father took me
through this. I, she was me
without getting choked up.
[inaudible] my father took me to this
lecture and then I show ne who like warm
rose
[inaudible] and when all the people
got a kick into the ice and snow in on
almost [inaudible] this
full walk for a walk,
for in search of
knowledge. [inaudible] idea
as he tells it on those tapes. That
was the beginning of his big idea.
That was gonna change the
world. Fast forward a few years,
they came to Ghana after
the first girl. Wow.
Did end up going to the
Technical University of Vienna.
I was suddenly discovered to be the best
mandolin player in Australia and one
time I played with a full opera orchestra,
[inaudible] composer Francesca.
So those were the days
and then everything changed. In 1938
[inaudible] artist came to
town, Nazis came to town,
he was sent to Depauw and then Buchenwald
you know the concentration camps,
one of those feelings
will be showing desire.
No, I mean go on. All around him.
People were being worked to
death or outright exterminated,
but his wife Claire was a
German Catholic with connections
and clear my goodbye, sluggish,
my mandolin and my guitar and into
the concentration came [inaudible].
I became so famous among the
notches. That's, for instance,
I block fear would come
into our, but I can say rich
[inaudible] and you could
say that it was [inaudible]
here in Buchenwald that Carl started
to develop his ideas about language,
about the ways that you can
manipulate words. For instance,
there was this one song that
all the prisoners saying, Yep,
Oh, who buys leads? One of the
status songs I can ever mean pad
the saddest lyrics in the
world. At a certain point,
Carl started to play around
with this song. You know,
he'd swap out some of the
sad lyrics for some jokes,
sing it for his fellow prisoners
and then laughed and laughed and laughed
and forgot for a few minutes that the
orange, the darkest and the
most terrible homes on air.
And on the flip side,
every evening the guards would
march all the prisoners outside,
force them to stand there in the
cold, in front of these loudspeakers,
make them listen to these speeches,
no
speeches of Hitler and
Gerbils screaming Nazi slogan.
[inaudible]
which means Germany above all.
No, no, no. Starting the race
back last year we weren't,
which [inaudible] which judge you mean?
But after about a year,
his wife somehow wrangled a British
visa for him and he gets out
and Kevin's shows dreadful times are
gone and now I can play here for you and
improvisation as it comes
into my mind. [inaudible]
in 1939 he went to Britain
and then got a job as
a manager of a factory,
but he arrived in England just as
[inaudible].
The blitz begins, the Germans start
to bomb every major city in England.
The noise that you hear at the moment
is the sound of the air raid siren.
And every time he'd introduce himself
to somebody new they they'd shutter.
That can't be your name. Yeah, because
of like blitzkrieg add that associate.
Yes.
Yeah, go ahead. I'll get a good bid.
There's name like blitz and so I
changed from the war, like [inaudible]
to the piece [inaudible]
that was how he became Charles Bliss.
Bliss has all the right associations,
so he went forward with the feeling of
that he was now bliss and would bring
happiness to the world.
And a year later he and his wife ended
up in China in Shanghai where there was a
big population of Xcel, Jews.
Shanghai was the only place
that would take them at that
time
and they're in China and that in China,
I got the opportunity of my lifetime
and now we come to his big idea.
I realized what I did not know that the
Chinese have a different way of writing.
He became enraptured by the
Chinese writing that he saw
the Chinese use symbols and each symbol
is a word and he writes about having
this epiphany when he saw
the Chinese symbol for man,
he saw that the Chinese written form
of man sort of looks like a man.
It looks like a sick freaking
man and it means man,
he doesn't even know what
the Chinese word for man is.
He doesn't know how to say
man, but that doesn't matter.
He is skipping the word and
going directly into the meaning.
So here was a way of
getting beyond language.
You could think of the word in any
language if you see it in the symbol.
And that was a revelation. Why? Well,
I mean,
think back to the concentration camps
when they were outside in front of those
loudspeakers listening to
Hitler's saying stuff like
Deutschland,
Uber, Alice, you know, Germany
above all that phrase [inaudible]
Charles knew that it
actually predated the Nazi.
That was cool a hundred
years earlier in 1848
and originally it was meant as a rallying
cry to bring together all of these
separate principalities.
You see the robot barrier,
the Kingdom of structure
that spoke German, but
these were not one country.
So when they said Deutschland
numerology, it meant university
unified Germany,
the nation above the states. Oh, suit
wasn't necessarily an aggressive thing.
Yeah,
no, but that's good to turn this around.
Hitler changed the meaning instead
of the nation above all states.
He changed it to the nation.
Never seen conventional. The word bubble,
all other nations. So
you see what happened,
this phrase that started meaning
one thing. Unification. Yeah.
Became the opposite. Yeah.
This is what the Nazis did.
Tools works nice.
It would bend words to obscure the truth
of what they were doing. Extermination.
They'd call it solution. By
doing that. As he saw it,
they were able to convince
good, same people,
his neighbors to go along
with the genocide. [inaudible]
then I realized that trenching must
be done to make language more to it,
to nature.
Words were the problem. Words made people
do cruel things to each other. Okay.
Then I society apart, words
were dangerous instruments.
They caused violence. They cause wars.
So when he saw the Chinese symbol for
man, he thought this might be the answer,
and the idea came up to me that I would
should invent symbols like the Chinese
symbols,
but even clearer [inaudible] simple and
pictorial that even children can read
them.
If he could sit down and work it out.
You look at the symbol and
know what it meant instantly,
regardless of what language you spoke,
you wouldn't even need words which
he felt could be manipulated.
You could just have the symbol and get
straight to the truth of the manner and
the way he saw it. Right off the bat,
you'd have all of these benefits. Wrench,
Mindan, Finnish, English.
When an Estonian language
barriers would be out the window.
Everything from traffic accidents
to health problems could be avoided.
He thought if his symbol
system would just be adopted.
He had this vision that
high level political and
commercial negotiations would
be done in symbols.
Did he say anything as grand as like or
wouldn't happen constantly and even of
course
he reckon Hitler wouldn't have happened
basically that if the German people had
understood the symbols, they wouldn't
have copped gerbils propaganda. Yeah.
That's a pretty tall order, but
it did seem to be what he thought.
Everything could be cured by this system.
He's the biggest dreamer ever. Yeah.
How did he go about doing this?
He started working out with the
basic lines and shapes would be,
he also wanted to make sure you
could produce it with a typewriter,
so it had to be a limited set of
shapes out of which everything could be
created.
Okay. So he works on it for
seven years, seven years,
and he comes up with that.
Wow. That is a big way.
This massive book called list
symbolics, semantic Ology,
illogical writing for an
illogical world that says it all,
where he explains the logic of
his system. For example here,
here's a symbol for sword, which
looks exactly like a sword.
And then the sword plus a forward
Arrow means attack. I buy it.
And then if you see a symbol for sword
and another symbol for sword and they're
cross, that means war.
So that's the idea that you take these
basic elemental symbols and combine them.
Exactly. All right. Here's another one.
This symbol here is like the top half
of a circle, like a little rainbow,
but just one line that means mind, mind,
it looks like the top of his skull. Ah.
Now if I were to take that symbol from
mind and I were to go like this or to put
inside it, the question
mark, that means, um,
I don't know or I have no doubt.
And, and there are also, you know,
ways to indicate verbs and adjectives
and first person, second person,
the past, the future.
But kind of the one thing that it did
that no other language or symbol system or
anything has attempted to do,
at least as far as I know,
is that it would make clear
when something was, um, well,
he called the human evaluation,
you know, basically an opinion.
And what you would do
is you put this little,
this Little v symbol and you put it
above this symbol and y, y v. Well,
because you know,
a v is balanced on a point and
it's unstable at wobbles to him.
That represents opinion's
human evaluations.
Anything that comes out in
the mind or take metaphors
[inaudible]
four as he says, you must put up
[inaudible] to alert the reader.
Do not take this. Literally stop at that
for a head. Not exactly bulletproof,
but I can, I can see
the, the thinking there.
I actually think it's pretty impressive
and okay, so what happens next?
Well after he finishes this and he and
his wife are living in Australia at the
time, they spent all their savings on
producing this book and sent it out to
professors, government officials, heads
of state, something like 6,000 people.
And they waited for the orders
to start rolling in and um,
no response from anybody.
And then they had nothing. [inaudible]
I can't say. I didn't
see that coming. Yeah.
And with great disappointment,
Charles went to work as a welder and yeah,
factory, the General Motors.
Holden's he was working on the
production line almost as a robot.
And a year later his wife died. You know,
he had fought in world war one. He
had been in a concentration camp.
He had lived in exile, but he says
this was the lowest point of his life
until one day, 1971 this, as he said,
this letter floated onto his desk.
Yeah.
With this picture of this
beautiful dimpled child,
proudly using his symbols. Yeah.
It was a poster, a poster,
a poster. This is Shirley,
Shirley McNaughton and at the time she
was a nurse at a place called D o c c c
the Ontario crippled children's center
and named that we were very happy to
leave behind us and they've
since changed in the name.
I started there in 1968 and surely was
part of this group of teachers and nurses
who worked with these kids who
suffered from cerebral palsy.
If you have cerebral palsy,
it's the motor control from
the brain that's been affected,
which meant that they had trouble moving
their arms or legs and even in some
cases they couldn't speak.
They couldn't form words and then
a film that was made of this class.
Ah, you see these young kids,
children from five to seven all sitting
in wheelchairs and they're watching the
teacher. Oh,
she talks to them and you
hear them try to talk to her,
but they can't. These kids
had no way to communicate
and they learn how to read.
They could if you knew what they were
understanding and they have no way to
communicate that to you.
The only thing all these kids had were
pictures that they could point at.
They had a picture of a toilet
picture of food, a picture of a drink,
a of a bad, they were limited
to that kind of communication.
But I knew they were bright. But if they
couldn't move and they couldn't speak,
how would you know? My uh, insight on
that was the twinkle in their eyes.
But she says a lot of doctors and nurses
at the time thought I was crazy that
there really wasn't much going on
inside these kids' heads. You know,
they thought I was projecting
into the children what she needed.
She said was a way to get through to them.
And so one day she was at the library
with a colleague and they come across this
dusty old volume that had
never been checked out. Called,
you guessed it with symbol likes. And
what did you first think when you saw it?
Oh boy, can I get back to the group?
How fast can I get back to the group
with this exactly what we need.
So do you remember what the first
symbols were? I think it was, I you,
I looked kind of like a
standing person. Upright line,
small horizontal line at the base.
Yeah, next to it, the number one,
which means first person you is the same
symbol but with a number two for second
person.
And then they had to have a verb and
it was lung heart with an air threat.
So now they've got a sentence. I love you.
Uh,
one of our mothers as the happiest moment
she's ever had with her child was when
her child came home and said,
I love you. You know, so
surely. And her staff
started to add more symbol.
They caught on and pretty soon they'd
created this giant laminated chart.
It had I and you and he, she, we and they,
then it had mother, father,
grandma, grandpa, doctor,
nurse, teacher, therapist,
postman, environment, library, dentist.
Eventually they added adjectives, happy,
sad and frustrated. All the verbs
who had loved and like, and hey,
launch ne understand.
Pretty soon the kids started to do
amazing things with simple combinations.
They started to improvise. Surely
remembers asking one kid, Terry Martin,
what did you want to be refer Halloween?
Terry pointed first at the symbol for
creature, a creature, not a person.
Then he pointed it assemble for drinks
than blood ned night creature who drinks
blood at night. Right. You
want it to be of empire. Ah,
he spelled a new word.
It sounds like an explosion
with these kids. It was.
It was for the first time.
She says she could actually talk
to them like know who they were.
Yeah. You've got to know who the
leaders were in the classroom.
Those who wanted to help
others, those who copied others.
And it was around then that she and the
other teachers decided to send Charles
Bliss. That letter.
We were sharing our excitement for
this gift he'd given to the children.
You know, he was in Australia,
he was an elderly man.
We had no thought that he would
come and visit us, you know,
didn't enter our mind. But
Charles Bliss, he was delighted.
Very, very good.
He had battled for so long for
recognition and now he had it.
[inaudible]
mortgages his house and flies over,
paid my mandoline and told him jokes and
only dances around and kisses everybody
a few passively than
laughter. I love that. Hello?
You had long conversations
with the kids in symbols,
right? He was very happy
about the children. Joy,
joy,
okay. But somewhere along
the way, he notices something
surely, surely, and the
teachers had begun to
[inaudible]
augment the system.
They'd be going to add their own
symbols such as the opposite,
meaning symbol. This allowed the kids to
take one of blitzes, standard symbols,
and just invert the meaning, opposite
of happy, sad, opposite of up, down,
opposite of [inaudible] to her.
This would effectively double the number
of adjectives which would be great for
the kids and we developed rules for how
to combine symbols for how to be more
precise with the symbols. She threw in
some new pronouns that were missing.
The difference between he
and him and his. In short,
I would make the adaptations I needed
to make from the very beginning.
We were using it to meet
the children's needs,
their specific needs. And of course
that is not what he had in his mind.
He wanted a system that was universal.
Every change that she made
created like a separate dialect,
he would get very emotional about
it. So when he got back to Australia,
he started writing all these
letters basically taking
issue with her changes and
her failure to understand how
his system works. Meanwhile,
thanks to surely worried about blesses
symbols had spread way beyond Canada too.
France, Sweden, Israel,
Zimbabwe, Zimbabwe. Yeah.
And then Argentina, Brazil,
Finland, Iceland, Italy, Bermuda, Guam,
Japan, Portugal, Spain, Netherlands,
Hungary, Switzerland, Venezuela,
Madagascar, Yugoslavia.
It's spread to all these places. Yeah.
And in each place,
the symbols when inevitably get tweaked
to suit that country, for example,
in Israel because the writing
goes from right to left. Yeah.
The bliss symbols went
from right to left. Uh,
but what really pained him the most,
what really got him was that these
teachers were using his symbols as a step
toward English or French or
German or Hebrew or whatever.
It was just a way to get the
kids to their native languages.
The teachers always saw
it the way they saw it.
You start the kids on bliss and then
you introduce reading and letters and
eventually they're fully literate.
At which point you don't
need the bliss symbols.
This was the ultimate insult him.
They were using his system to bring
these kids back to the very thing that he
was trying to get everyone
away from evil words. Yeah,
why not? Why not?
If I tried to explain it to them, they
don't want donation to me, then look,
show me. What should I do?
I do that. I don't know.
I don't know
and it's right about this point in the
story that you start to hear a different
Charles Place.
Shannon, if Norton has
[inaudible] has been
better than [inaudible].
Is he saying perverted? Yeah,
she smiles. She be guys. She she lies.
He kept sending Shirley and the other
teachers letters and the letters got
angrier and angrier. This was
not what the language was for.
This was a universal language that had
nothing to do with spoken language.
You are ruining my system,
you are abusing it.
And eventually he decided to take matters
into his own hands and he traveled
back to Canada and he started going to
the various centers where the kids were
using his symbols and saying
horrible things about me. Uh,
and getting them very upset.
That's when I got upset.
I got upset when he got them upset. Not
long after Shirley receives a summer
I have taken to court.
Oh she, she in the beach?
He sued them. Yup.
I added two war dependents.
Mrs Chilling, ignored
on the tapes. Even suggest that
he's going to have Shirley put away,
put a whole life for life. Wow.
Why was he so upset with
her in particular? Well,
because by this time she'd started
the international organization,
B C Bliss Symbol,
communications international and she
felt like this was a total unique and
powerful tool which could,
could and should transform lives around
the world and more teachers needed to
adopt it. Definitely.
What was he asking for?
Did he wanted us to use
the symbols in his way?
So in 1975 the BCI won a license agreement
to use the symbols in the workbooks
for the kids. But Charles Bliss,
they should all be part, didn't
give up, they should all be powered.
He published endless tirades and sent
them out to anybody who is listening
and hopefully to educate
or oppose you to patients.
Or is the British chambers just all in all
this went on for over a decade and the
administration of the program or surely
was working was desperate
to make him go away.
He had basically destroyed the program.
And so in 1982 he and the BCI
finally come to an agreement.
Okay.
It was a financial settlement
that satisfied him.
What was the financial
settlement? $160,000.
Wow.
You know,
we were a little program in the basement
of the Ontario cripple children's
center. We were, you
know, just a classroom.
Wow. That,
so a guy who wanted to save the world
ends up robbing a bunch of disabled kids.
I mean, that's kind of putting it crudely,
but that's how this how it
feels basically. That's the,
yeah,
no.
Did the symbols ever go anywhere? Well,
there was a lot of excitement
about it in the beginning,
but it never spread very far.
It's used now at a few
schools in Canada and Sweden,
a couple other places. Uh,
but it never went very far because he
was constantly taking it down at every
turn.
[inaudible]
but here's what I find
most surprising. When I,
when I talked to Shirley, she didn't
have any bitterness toward him.
Not even in the worst moments when
we were having the final legal,
um, action.
We'd go through that in the morning
and as the layers were packing up their
papers, Charles Bliss would reach
across the table and he'd say,
surely will you help me? And so she'd
go to lunch with him, sit with him,
and then he asked me if I would come
to his hotel that night and put the
eardrops in his ears. And
I did that every night.
He was involved with this thing.
That's just the way it was.
And it wasn't just that she takes care
of people for a living, you know, she,
she felt and still feels that Charles
Bliss had created something really new in
the world. She even told me that
when she uses blessed symbols,
she actually thinks differently.
Yes, definitely. Really, definitely.
What's different? Oh, I just think
so much more about what a word means.
And it, it's, it's like
poetry in its purest form.
Um, I'm playing with stained glass
down here in my retirement and you can,
you know,
you can just take the symbols and put
them into one composite and they say
things that only art
can say. It's beautiful.
They transmit a meaning
that is beyond any words.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
thanks to producer Tim Howard and
Erica Okra and author of in the land of
invented languages. We'll be right back.
Bliss is having friends
and family you can rely on.
My name is Libby Graham and I am calling
from the side of the road in Dallas,
Texas awaiting rescue. This is
ginger, a socially awkward
introvert from Cabot, Arkansas.
Bliss is one day in which I do not have
to interact with another human being.
Bliss is political ignorance.
This is my moose from
Maria at places here.
Baby sleeping in here.
Hi, this is Erica Okra and
Radiolab is supported in part Radiolab
is supported in part by the national
science foundation and the Alfred
p Sloan Foundation enhancing public
understanding of science and
technology in the modern world.
More information about Sloan
can be found at www dot Sloan.
That org radio lab is produced by
W N Y C and distributed by n p.
R. Hope that works for you.
Thanks. And this message.
This is Brooklyn and I'm calling
from Walla Walla, Washington.
Radiolab is supported by Dell featuring
the powerful performance and incredible
battery life of the new Dell pcs with
Intel core processors empowering small
business employees to do their
best work wherever work takes them.
Dell's US-based small business advisors
and price match guarantee mean you'll
always get the best deal on the right
solution tailored to your business needs.
Powerful pcs are just the
beginning of a great partnership.
Call eight seven seven by Dell.
Now to contact a Dell small business
advisor today that's eight 77 by Dell.
Hi, I'm Robert Krulwich. Radiolab
is supported by Squarespace.
The simplest way to create
a website this new year,
make your next move with Squarespace.
Whether that's starting a business
or launching a passion project,
no matter what your goals are.
Squarespace's award winning templates
can help you present your ideas to the
world.
Beautifully use offer code radio lab
for 10% off your first purchase of a
Squarespace domain or website.
squarespace.com make your next move.
Make your next website.
Hey, what's up? I'm Jessica
Williams and I'm Phoebe Robinson.
We are back this spring with an
all new season of our hit podcast.
Tuto Queen's from WWE
NYC studio. It's comedy.
It's conversation with your fave celeb.
It's me and Jeff telling tribe stories
about my bought up session. Gross. Dude,
why are you even bringing
that up right now? Anyway,
this season you'll hear from John Ham.
Drew Bronson did. Kitaro gave her union.
Oh my pits are sweating. Just
thinking about damn girl.
Come on over to two dope queens.
Wherever you get your pod and bond.
I'll call me.
Wait, wait, wait. Don't
shoot. Let me just hit record.
Okay. And now, what were you saying
spontaneously a moment ago? Hey,
I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert
Krulwich, Radiolab, and today bliss.
And in our last segment,
we met a guy who dreamt of a perfect world
where words can never muck things up.
It got a little carried away.
Yeah. So let's forget about dreams.
Now we're going to look for perfection
right here in the physical world. Okay.
So, so, so this story, and we're
going to do it with a perfect person.
Latif Nasser, it begins with
a, with a birthday present.
It's February 9th,
1886 miles outside the tiny town of
Jericho, Vermont. And we're on a farm,
a family farm, uh,
the Bentley family farm and the scrawny
15 year old kid named Wilson gets a
microscope from his mother. So
it's February and it's Vermont.
And so naturally, the first thing this
kid does is he grabs a handful of snow,
picks out a single flake, and he
puts it under the microscope. And
what he sees is, is the most
beautiful thing he's ever seen.
It's is ethereal and, and perfect.
He calls them masterpieces
as as if they're these, you
know, great works of art.
He calls him that in his 15
year old diary. Looking back,
he talked about that moment and
what he was thinking when he,
when he sort of first saw
it, but obviously, you know,
within minutes or maybe even seconds,
these masterpieces just disappeared
without leaving any evidence that
they, that they ever existed.
They just sort of evaporate.
Huh. And as he remembers it, he,
he sort of decides then in there that
he's going to dedicate his whole life to,
to documenting these masterpieces.
Otherwise no one will ever
know they even existed.
He's gonna spend his whole
life documenting snowflakes.
Yeah. It's a good life,
Jed. And it pays well. Right.
That's exactly what his father said.
His father thought he was, you know,
he was just was lazy and didn't want
to do the farming chores as far as his
milk, the goats. And he goes, now
the beauty, the beauty. Right, right.
And apparently he was a real, he
was really good at digging potatoes,
but he just sort of was so busy futzing
around with his microscope that he,
you know, I don't like this kid,
I don't like him. The friends,
your work ethic so fed up it's neck. So,
so he takes his microscope and he,
he moves it to this unheated
woodshed behind the house. Um, and,
and he starts sketching
these snowflakes, right?
And while he's sketching,
you can't even breathe because he was
worried that his breath would melt his
specimen. So he's sort of
holding his breath and, and, and,
and drawing these, you know,
these extremely complex crystals
that can take you maybe, you know,
maybe an hour to draw, but, but depending
on the temperature, the humidity,
the size of the crystal he had at
most, he had five minutes, right
at the end of that, he, he looks
at the mall and he's not satisfied.
He just felt like he
wasn't doing it justice.
You know what he calls these
like miracles of beauty.
So Bentley persuades his mother who
persuades his father to buy him a camera.
Whey is I go, wait, wait, wait,
wait. 1880, we're in February,
1880 have we entered into,
in the era of picture taking just
just and for a farming family,
this was like a lot of money, but
they buy it for him and he gets it.
Any sort of Jerry rigs it to
the microscope. And at age 19,
Wilson Bentley is the first person ever
in history to photograph a snowflake.
Okay. I'm going to cue the snowflake
celebration in secure, right
[inaudible]
from then on, basically for the
next 46 winters until he died.
Every, every snowfall,
every blizzard is a Bentley would stand
in the doorway of his little shack, uh,
holding out a wooden tray, uh, with,
with thick mittens cause
you would wear these,
they're almost like oven mitts
to, to, to make sure that his,
none of his body heat
would kind of leak out and,
and inadvertently melt any of the snow.
So He'd sort of stand there and sort
of give it a once over with his eye.
If nothing was promising.
He, he basically had a,
a Turkey feather and he would sort of
just wipe it clean with this Turkey
feather until he did find something
you liked. And then he would,
he would take this tiny little wooden
rod and he would just certain really
delicately tap the center of the
crystal and like really, really,
really gently lifted off and
then transfer it onto the,
onto a glass slide so that he could put
it under the microscope and he could
photograph it. Over
the course of his life.
He'd basically photographed about
5,000 snow crystals for his whole life.
He was just a farmer doing
this kind of as a hobby. Uh,
but he sold copies of these photos for
5 cents a pop to places like Harvard and
the British Museum and the u s
weather bureau, research journals,
magazines like nature and
national geographic. And I mean,
you've already seen the photos, like
you've gotten them on a Christmas card,
they're on your like ugly Christmas
sweater in your closet somewhere. Um,
we're throwing a shirt with
them on right now. Yeah.
Um, they're, they're, they're,
they're everywhere. They're beautiful,
symmetrical, really clean. And Complex.
A lot of the greatest scientists who
ever lived like Descartes and Kepler and
Hook,
they all tried to sketch and draw and
kind of capture the essence of snowflakes.
But none of them could do it as well as
this one obsessive loaner from Jericho,
Vermont, whose photos were perceived to
be kind of more faithful to nature than,
than, than anybody else.
But that was until, um,
this,
the guy came on the scene,
this German guy who the other
Guy Germanic theme music. Yes.
Yes.
[inaudible] he was a German
meteorologist named Gustaf helmet stuff.
Hell man. Not of the mayonnaise
fame, I don't believe. Um,
I haven't even thought of that
actually. It's a helmet. Is this a,
is he a contemporary of
Bentley? Yeah, he is.
And he's working on his own book
about weather and so he hires a,
a kind of a micro photographer who's
another German guy named Newhouse.
Mike Grace is a very teeny
photographer who he kept on his desk.
He's a microscopic himself and he
just takes normal size photographs.
Anyhow,
he hires this guy in and they take a
bunch of photos using basically similar
technology camera and I'm
like, are scope essentially.
But what they find is totally different.
They do not find the, the,
the elegance and metrical ideal snow
crystals that Bentley found that the
crystals they found were like flawed,
lopsided, usually like broken.
And the way I think of it,
it was like a Martian who had only ever
seen like glossy fashion magazines had
just been given some like random family
photo album and it was like, Oh wow,
this is, they're not so pretty. Like
these are kind of ugly, you know,
humans, humans, they're not
all symmetrical. These Germans,
they, they basically
called them out. They,
they basically thought
Bentley was a fraud.
There was a particular way that
Bentley prepared his photographs.
What he would do is he would use a pen
knife to scrape the negative around the
snow crystal,
which is what gave it that kind of Nice
black background because he thought it
would kind of put it in maybe
starker relief. Um, and, and,
and the German guys said that's it's,
it's misleading that it kind of
mutilates the snowflakes, um, away.
So he's photographing these snowflakes
and then significantly messing with the
photograph. Exactly right. Exactly right.
So here's a quote from the photographer
who said, quote a, in many images,
Bentley did not limit himself
to improving the outlines.
He let his knife play deep inside the
heart of the crystals so that fully
arbitrary figures emerged.
So he said, oh, I don't know.
That doesn't seem so no longer a
candidate, is it? Well, that's,
that's the question. So then, but then,
so they basically lobbed this and
that this is kind of going into these
journals, but Bentley basically
launches a counter attack.
And what he says is that in
fact those guys are wrong,
that not correcting
your photographs was an,
he used this word like perverse to him.
Why wouldn't you remove specks
of dust or other imperfections?
Why photograph of a broken snowflake
when you could photograph a complete one?
So this is a quote from Bentley. He said
a true scientist, which is above all,
to have his photographs as
true to nature as possible.
And if retouching will help in this
respect than it is fully justified.
So he thought his retouched snowflakes
were truer than the normal ones.
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
That the scientist is supposed to
be kind of this very experienced,
almost like a sage who is seen every
different variation on a snowflake,
but can sort of bring that
all together in one drawing,
one sketch, one photograph,
and that's the true snowflake.
So if I brought him a slightly
gloppy snowflake and said,
look,
this is what fell on my nose and this
is a true snowflake because it actually
fell from the sky and it's, you
know, it was an [inaudible] enhanced
you. He would say that Robert, you're,
you're an amateur. Like this is,
this is not good work. You know, this is
an aberration. This is an abnormality.
Why would you choose to kind of highlight
an abnormality as opposed to kind of
this, this true ideal snowflake,
you know, and does that one exist?
I mean, that's the key question for me.
Like does the ideal
snowflake exist in nature?
You think there are such
things I exquisitely beautiful.
I would like to think that there are no,
so I think if my facts are right,
the world's snowflake expert is
actually in, in Pasadena. Califia
all right. Check, check,
check, check, check in.
Can Sunny Southern California.
Yeah, I'm wearing a tee shirt.
I have sunscreen lathered and I am going
to talk to the world authority on snow.
How are you? His name is Ken Lee Brecht.
He's up a professor of physics
at cal tech. He is in a way,
he's like the modern day Wilson Bentley
because he takes a ton of of snowflake
pictures taken about 10,000 now. And uh,
and he actually makes snowflakes.
Oh yeah. Artificially. Okay.
Wow. So this is a giant tank. This
is a nitrogen here. Nevermind that.
And to get to your question about
the ideal snowflake, a few things.
So number one, they're a
bajillion different kinds,
dendritic crystal, stellar dendrites,
needles and columns and hollow
columns and a sector of plates.
That's one thing. The second thing
is that snowflakes are never static.
They're never one thing. So what every
single moment as it falls to the earth,
it's either growing or shrinking depending
on the kind of trajectory through the
different pockets of
weather as it's moving down.
So there is no real platonic ideal
form of a snowflake because it's,
it's, it's so influx.
I mean there's no such thing
as a perfect snowflake,
but that doesn't stop only brag
from, from looking, you know,
I tried up in Tahoe and Japan, Vermont,
Michigan travels all over the world
looking for Bentley's perfect flakes.
I'll ask, I've been to Alaska, Sweden,
but my favorite spot is northern Ontario
little town called Cochran population
5,487. So where do you go in
Cochran? Do you just, just anywhere.
They're just falling all over the
place. Mostly it's the, it's the uh,
parking lot of my, my hotel besides,
there's a lot of waiting involved.
It only really snows
well about once a week.
Even then things have to be goldilocks
perfect. If the clouds are too high,
then they evaporate a
little on the way down.
They look pretty or if the clouds too
light or too heavy, that's about two.
And a lot of times the temperature is
wrong. If you want those Christmas cards,
supermodel snowflakes, uh,
you need to have exactly minus 15
that's five degrees Fahrenheit.
You need to have high humidity,
not so much wind so that they'll putter
down slowly and have more time to grow.
But every once in awhile, I mean,
when the conditions are right,
you'd go outside all hopeful and
dissipating and it's like, oh crap,
there's nothing garbage at here.
So you back go back inside and read some
more email and you come back a half an
hour later, nope, still lousy and half
hour later, nope, still allows it.
And you know,
you do this for hours and then all
of a sudden they'll get really good
[inaudible] just start there
and frantically trying to
collect as many as I can.
Well, one of the things I like
to think about this is, you know,
here I am with my little piece of
cardboard in the middle of a continent is
snowing on time.
And so I am catching some incredibly
small number of these things for a brief
period and, and getting
some really cool pictures.
And so you kind of wonder what the,
what else is out there
and what are you missing?
I mean imagine just all the beautiful
little works of art that are just falling
down totally unnoticed and
then they just disappear.
I mean stuff that is far
prettier than, you know,
the pictures I have cause
they're out there, you know,
they're out there statistically
they are out there and so you know,
there's just an awful lot
of really gorgeous things.
It's just are like you say,
they're just totally a femoral and
you'll never see them and they're falling
constantly. So you sort of want to
just stop the world and you know,
go look at them.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
thanks a lot. Diff Nasser and to Ken Leeb,
Rick who wrote the book the
secret life of a snowflake.
[inaudible]
this is Matt and Dawson from Asheville,
North Carolina and bliss is this sound.
That's the sound of my seven month year
old daughter reacting to my puppy dog
licking her feet. Hi,
my name is Igor and I'm calling
from north Northside Serbia.
Bless this Indiana Jones, all free parts
radio lab.
This is Steve Strogatz
bliss is the taste of HACCP.
Pastrami at Katz's Deli in the
lower east side of New York City.
We live, we're five hours away from New
York and don't get there very often.
So I spend a lot of time in between
visits thinking about that first taste hot
pastrami. So for me,
that's plus I get to think about
some kind of almost unattainable
except that it is attainable.
I just show up in there it is.
This is Mary Roach and I'm in Oakland,
California and I have a list of lists,
my bliss list number one, laughing
uncontrollably. Number two,
zero gravity number for the first
10 seconds in a hot hot bath.
Number nine, a raw oyster, very fresh,
but no larger than infants here.
This is Adrian stone from
New Brunswick, New Jersey.
Radiolab is supported in part by the
National Science Foundation and by the
Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science
and technology in the modern world.
More information about
Sloan at www dot Sloan
[inaudible] dot org
hi, I'm Robert Krulwich. Radiolab
is supported by Squarespace.
The simplest way to create
a website this new year.
Make your next move with Squarespace.
Whether that's starting a business
or launching a passion project,
no matter what your goals are.
Squarespace's award-winning templates
can help you present your ideas to the
world.
Beautifully use offer code Radiolab
for 10% off your first purchase of a
Squarespace domain or website.
squarespace.com make your next move.
Make your next website.
Hey, I'm Jana. Boom.
Rod. I'm Robert Krulwich.
This is radio lab and we're
talking about bliss so far.
I'm going to say we're not doing so
great. I mean we had a fleeting moment,
a dream that crumbled snowflakes
and evaporate in your hand,
but in the next story we're going
to shoot for bliss that lasts.
Hello, this is Mike in a Mike speak
up. Andy comes to us from our producer,
Andy Mills. Can you hear me? I can
hear Ya. All right, so set this up.
Who is this guy? His name
is Mike Young. Right?
I called him up because of something that
happened to him a little over 50 years
ago. Let's see,
this was 1962 is something that he still
thinks about all these years later.
I was in my early twenties
22 something like that.
21 he was an undergraduate
at a theological school
in Boston and one day he
received a very different
kind of religious education,
a very different kind of [inaudible]
though he event occurred on Good Friday
and it happened at the Boston
University Marsh Chapel.
He was sitting, not up in the main chapel,
but down in the little basement chapel,
and he was sitting with about
19 of his fellow classmates.
The Meditation Service was being piped
down to us from the chapel above.
They have speakers in the front of this
little chapel in the basement with organ
music and an excellent choir
and the voice of the preacher
[inaudible]
is this kind of famous guy named
Howard Thurman and we relaxed.
We're all good
and interesting ideas began
going off in my head. Wow.
Sometimes it was hard to pay attention
to what was going on in the room.
The things that resist than defy
and to,
we slid jet a right into the
silicide been experienced
what we did, he said silicide
yes. Was in magic mushrooms,
SRE, shrooms. You're gonna
have to explain that one.
This was actually something called
the Marsh Chapel experiment,
the Marsh Chapel experiment. And
it was run by this guy and let me,
his name was Walter Panky.
Very briefly summarize the man,
he was a graduate student at Harvard at
this time and he was studying religious
experience.
No, this has also been
called the cosmic experience.
The transcendental experience
or the mystical. Which brands,
what exactly was he looking at? You know,
like, um, Christians, Muslims, Jews,
mystics. Like what kind of things
do they all have in common?
So he did a bunch of research
and interviews and he came
up with a basic catalog
of the ingredients in
a religious experience.
And one day he's at
Harvard and he bumps into
turn on [inaudible] and drop out
that guy, Timothy Leary, he was actually
a teacher at Harvard at the time.
And he was famously giving
psychedelic drugs to undergrads.
They're teaching people how to
use very head. Yeah. Point is,
and in order to use your head,
you have to go out of your mind.
And when Panky got a chance to talk
to these students who had tripped,
he noticed pretty quick that they used
really similar language to the people
that he'd been studying.
And he started to wonder,
if you put people into the right
situation and you give them this drug,
could you induce actually
induce a religious experience?
So on that day in 1962 pinky
put 20 theological school
students into this church
basement. You know, during
this Good Friday service,
10 of them got a placebo and then 10
of them got a hefty dose of Psilocybin,
things in the room morphing,
which brings us back to Mike Young.
You would move your head and there'd
be an after image from the lights.
One point the visual effect
was especially powerful
and he had this one moment that
has just stuck with him ever since.
He's in the middle of a technicolor.
See there were bars of color and I was
floating through them and they were
floating through me, uh,
and it was just glorious.
And the bars of color then
resolved I into a wheel.
I was at the center and there was a
different color going out from me in every
possible direction. At first,
this was quite nice. Uh,
and then I realized that I had to
swim out one of those color bars
I had to.
And each of those different color
bars would be a whole different life
experience. And I could
choose anyone of those,
a la life experience
color bars that I wanted,
but I had to choose one
and I couldn't choose one.
It was very painful. It felt like my
insides were being ripped out of me
and I died.
And at that moment that I died, uh,
I heard Howard Thurman say,
I shall die,
but that is all that I shall do for death.
And I stopped dying.
Wow. Wow.
What are we supposed to make of that?
It is, it is strange. Yeah. And in fact,
this is actually right around the time
that there's this huge cultural backlash
against this drug.
By the end of 1962 you've got Harvard
making the decision that these experiments
are not going to be done at their
university anymore. 63 evil man,
they fire Timothy Leary, empathy,
leery. He's out of there.
1970 congress outlaws, psychedelics, 1971
nearly every country in the world,
including the United States,
bans them from research is their
signatory to an international law.
Banning the use sail cultivation and
possession of dangerous drugs that have no
useful place in medicine.
I mean, on some level,
like I get that because like what
could you learn from a bunch of people
tripping like scientific. I mean,
I think that there actually is something
that we can learn from this. What?
Well, if you look at Mike Young on the
day that he walked into that chapel,
I was still a theological school
student. He was, you know,
he's experiencing doubts
without any real confidence.
That ministry was something
I was going to stay in.
But after this experiment at the chapel,
he went home to his wife
and uh, when I walked in,
my wife was very much aware that something
rather unusual had occurred to this
guy she was married to. Did she
just, you carry yourself differently?
You should never been that explicit
about it. She just said she knew that,
that I had had some kind of
a major experience at first.
He just kind of wrote the whole
thing off, but time passed.
He couldn't stop thinking about the
death and the rebirth experience.
And to make a long story
short, if you fast forward,
I'm a unitarian universalist minister, um,
as a result of partly a result
of that drug experience.
I want to share with you
this morning, a little exit.
Jesus of the New Testament.
That's him. Yeah.
Story of the Good Samaritan.
He has been preaching for 45 years here.
Here's the thing that I
think it is really strange.
All of the people who took the drug that
day, those 10 who got the silicide but,
and not the placebo,
all but one that came.
Ministers really. So nine out
of 10 went into the mystery.
Nine out of 10 what about the others?
The Placebo Group? Yeah. None.
None according to Mike. Absolutely
none. Wow. That is interesting.
That was the first thing I was
like, wow, that's, that's crazy.
But at the same time, you know
it's really small sample set.
Who knows why anyone becomes a minister.
I'm sure it wasn't just the drugs.
You know, maybe they didn't even play
that big of a role for everyone else,
but this did make me, you
know, like more curious
what exactly is happening to people when
they take this drug and I was surprised
to find out that like right now there
are actually a few laboratories who are
starting to experiment with these
drugs. Again, we thought, well why not?
This is Roland, Roland
Griffis psychopharmacologist.
I studied the effects
of drugs on behavior.
He's at Johns Hopkins and
Hopkins for 40 years now.
He's really well known for
studying nicotine and Ritalin,
but he tells me that back in 2000 he
was reading about the old psilocybin
studies from the 60s and this is right
around the time when the Drug Enforcement
Administration and the FDA were starting
to loosen their rules on experimenting
with psychedelics so he applies and he
gets approval study of that Short had not
been approved for 30 years and I can
tell you that I've never had a protocol
that was as rigorously and carefully
reviewed and scrutinized from every angle
since no one had studied this
drug for like three decades.
He started with some
really basic questions.
How does this affect behavior
after people have taken this drug?
Like did they feel confused or
afraid? Is it habit forming?
And how we did this test was he has this
lab room at Johns Hopkins that he's,
he's made like really
nice and cozy. It's a,
it's an aesthetic living
room like environment.
There's a couch and the stereo
system. Then one at a time,
volunteers brought in and given a
hefty dose of psilocybin blindfolded,
and then they're asked to lay down
and direct their attention inward.
We were bringing people in two months
after sessions and asking them so, well,
you know, what was the session like?
And they filled out some questionnaires.
And the thing
that I really wasn't prepared for
was how salient and important these
experiences were said to
be on follow up. You know,
they were saying, well, it was really
important, you know, and I would say,
well, how important? And
they would say, oh, well,
it was the most important experience
in my life. And I'd go, what?
And they would say, yeah, you
know, it's like, um, you know,
like when my daughter was born,
that changed my world forever.
I recently lost my father and,
um, and I'll never forget that.
And they'll say, you know,
it's Kinda like that.
And that's a totally
improbable. So we didn't,
we didn't have any metric that
could even assess that. So,
and what made things even weirder
for Rollin is that when he gave these
volunteers a questionnaire,
about 75% of people are saying it's in
the top five most personally meaningful
and spiritually significant experiences
that there lie a vast majority.
We're talking about like it's a
spiritual experience, huh? So rollin,
he went back to look at Pankey's
studies from the 1960s about the basic
ingredients that make up
a religious experience.
Let me look at the characteristic,
a very summary list first,
the characteristics of awe and wonder.
Everyone would report that they felt like
they were in the presence of something
great and enormous. Yeah.
The second characteristic is
transcendence of time and space.
People describe time slowing
down or space getting weird.
The third characteristic have to do with
mood very deeply felt positive. Mood.
Fourth, and I'm skipping over a few here.
Unity. This is a sense of cosmic oneness,
this feeling which basically intense
connection to everything around you.
The part of everything that is the whole
universe and even every blade of grass
and grain of sand and so forth.
These are words that people
use in describing in any way.
So based on this one guys, research
and keep in mind, you know,
a lot of people have
different opinions about this.
Roland believes that you can actually
take this little drug and for a majority
of people you can induce
a religious experience.
But I you don't, you, I don't know,
soon as you call it that then
I'm starting to think, hmm,
don't know [inaudible]
this is a real, a real,
I mean I don't know you guys,
but for someone who has to
take this very seriously,
because to say that you can pop a
pill and then in some shortcut fashion
suddenly get this experience that
hitherto had been very rare and had been
assigned the values of grace to say
that is to say any enormous thing.
Well it sounds like, it
sounds like you're not, I,
I'm guessing how you're taking it, Robert,
is to say that a d values the thing.
Yeah, I do value that. It kind of does
the opposite for me. Well, really,
I mean [inaudible]
when I hear these stories from, from
like all the people in these studies,
it reminds me like I've,
I've had these like very meaningful
experiences that I didn't think would last
on a pill. Did you have little or no,
not, not a pill. No drugs. So what,
so what happened? What, what
are you talking about? Well,
it goes back to like
when I was a Christian,
I used to be an evangelical Christian
and when I was about 15 I was at a church
camp and me and some of my best friends
were all gathered around a campfire.
He was hot and the stars
were all bright and shiny.
I remember they were playing
the song that I really liked.
And you know that feeling that you get
when when you in a crowd of people are
all singing like really loud some
song that you all really love. Yeah,
sure. And as we're all singing the song,
I remember my friend who wasn't raised
in the faith like me leaning over to me
and saying that like, he wanted to
accept Jesus and be a Christian.
And he asked, what am I supposed to
do? And I remember that being like,
great, great. It's not
even the word for it.
Like in this one moment I got caught up
in something that just felt so enormous.
It's hard for me to
explain how it's felt like.
It's hard to describe how I
felt like we were all one.
Like there was something
powerful that was,
that was like both over
us but also inside of us.
And so much has changed since then
that sometimes I look back and I think,
did that happen?
Like did I hallucinate like some dude
on drugs because that friend who,
uh, reached over to me, he's dead now.
That faith that I was a part of, I left it
like all I have is this weird feeling
that I can remember. That's good.
And even though you're not
a Christian anymore, you,
you still have that feeling. Oh yeah.
But what is it about the
idea that, that feeling,
that campfire feeling could be triggered
by a pill and that maybe that's what
was happening to those
folks in Rollins study?
What is it about that idea
that helps you? For me,
like I see something concrete,
you know, like I see,
I see. I see something that's
harder to write off. How so? Well,
if I can go back into reporter mode,
I will introduce you to one more guy who
I think is going to help you understand
what I'm talking about. Hello,
this is Charlie. Charlie Busan.
He's a longtime smoker. No, let's
start at 17 smoked for 40 years.
Pack a day. Breakfast, coffee,
talking on the phone. Wait.
Why are we talking about smoking? How
Roland's new study's doing right now?
His pilot program that he's
just started a few years ago.
[inaudible] is trying to see if there's
something in the transformation that you
have in, in the siliciden experience
that can help smokers quit smoking.
Really stick with me. They
gave me a pill, blue capsule,
and he closed his eyes and like Mike,
he says he had a hallucination
that changed him.
The thing that I found so amazing,
the one thing that was more amazing than
anything else was when I was on those
saw mountain. This is a
mountain in his head. Yes.
When I had traveled to
the very top, uh, I was,
uh, looking out over this greatness,
this vista of everything he says he
was just this microscopic thing he was,
he was so small and it was so big.
But my experience at this one place was
so exalted because he was struck by this
feeling,
this deep feeling that
we were the same thing.
We were the same.
This right here is another
hallmark of these experiences.
You're somehow confronted with this
radical shift in scale and things that
formerly felt like too big for
you to deal with. They suddenly,
they suddenly look different.
We had one person involved
in her cigarette smoking
study who had had a dose of
Psilocybin and in the
course of that session,
the idea of smoking came up
to him and he said, you know,
it was like a fly that had landed on his
arm and he just took his finger and he
flicked it off and he said he was
done with it. Done, done. [inaudible]
and that's exactly how it was for
Charlie. No morning afterwards.
He says he just didn't
want cigarettes anymore.
They just weren't an issue anymore.
Huh. And how long has he been off of it?
Three years. Wow. Now this
is just a tiny pilot program.
I don't think that we should
make too much out of it yet,
but the insight I feel
like is like, because,
because like Charlie has this
real experience, like it's not,
it's not a question of like
something invisible like faith,
but it's like a tangible reality for me.
It's like the closest thing I can come
to having some kind of real evidence that
what happened to me was real
with the campfire. Right. To me,
the mystery is you've done this occasional
thing with an artificial stimulus,
had a extraordinary with temporary
feeling and then mysteriously it isn't
temporary. He just goes on and on. Yeah.
Do we have any idea why it persists?
Well, Roland has a very educated hunch.
I asked him about this and he's looking
right now at getting in there and doing
research with some new SMRI machines.
But his hunch is that the
siliciden drug experience,
it somehow rewires the brain.
We're talking about rewiring a personality
and a fundamental machine programming
level. Like he calls this
experience a rearranging experience.
Huh? You know, maybe,
maybe one day science,
we'll figure out what's happening in the
brain of a person that's experiencing
something like this.
But one of the things about this that
troubles me like as a reporter and then
even like personally is that
going back to Walter Panky,
like remember his list of ingredients
from earlier, his final characteristic.
Yeah.
The final characteristic that
I'd like to mention here,
final ingredient was
the characteristic of
alleged enough ability,
which means that the people who have
such an experience claim that it can't be
described in words, that it's
nonverbal, basically indescribable.
And that's one of the main things that
I'm going to take away from all this.
I mean,
talking to Roland and Mike and Charlie
is just how hard it is to talk about the
thing that I've just spent
the last 20 minutes trying
to talk about. I understood something,
some, um,
life, uh,
suddenly eternal truth.
These words really don't match
the thing. I was at the top,
I was feeling divine source of,
um, of, um,
self awareness that I'm sorry,
said trick of words. I guess it's a
got
larger thanks to producer Andy Mills.
Thanks to you guys for listening.